okay two voicemails today we have been
doing this Jenga thing where for every
two patreon contributions I pull a Jenga
piece and eventually when this fall's
we'll double the number of moves I was
able to make and create a membership
discount code so right now we are at 29
yes yeah I keep getting confused we've
moved 29 pieces meaning if on the next
move the tower falls we do a 58%
membership discount code here's one idea
for what I should do next
to promote patreon contributions hey
David I was thinking about it and I
think after you're done with the Jenga
game to raise patreon subscribers you
should bring a carrying machine in and
once you hit 2500 patrons you up the
ante and you and pat destroy a carrot
machine on an episode yeah that might
bring people in Baba Booey to you I
thank you I am NOT that might be the
first time we've been Baba Booey did I
actually know I think that the late
great Joey boots who sadly passed some
some months ago maybe even more than a
year ago who was a big he was a Howard
Stern whack Packer and also fan of the
David Pakman show I think he Baba Booey
just once and I'm not exactly sure about
that yeah that I would be up for that it
reminds me of this scene in office space
where they get this copier that always
jams and they beat the thing to hell in
a field with baseball bats we could get
a Keurig and we could we could destroy
it although now Keurig is friendly too
right because they're participating in
boycotting the Sean Hannity program in
terms of advertising I mean my first
thought would was why would I want to
destroy a Keurig because I love cure it
yeah then I realized you also didn't
want to come in with your hair out of
control either yeah it's the idea I
think would be we do something that we
wouldn't really like doing normally and
Pat would Pat would rather pull a cup of
coffee out of the Keurig then actually
destroy the thing but that's one
possibility
here's another idea for what we could do
when the Jenga tower ultimately Falls
patreon subscribers should be to shave
your head mmm I think everybody would
like to feel that look like that on TV
ya know save it on TV on air yeah even
funnier so at 2,000 patrons I puffed my
hair without any product and we did that
early last week and the idea here is
what if I agreed to shave my head fully
on-camera for the next patreon goal I'm
gonna be a super upfront I'm willing to
consider that but it's gotta be
something like 5,000 or 7500 patron you
would shave your head I would consider
shaving my head because listen if we got
to like 7500 patrons the level of
financial independence that we would
have would be significant and listen
I'll wear a hat for a few months until
it grows back well I would be willing to
shave my head on the show and and sort
of see but but we it would really have
to be worthwhile it would probably have
to be like 7,500 patrons or something
that Amit Ben David I don't know I'm not
committing to it right now I'm saying
that if there's a desire for it and we
established some number of patrons
that's logical it's on the table
if shaving the head is on the table okay
on the bonus show today we will talk
about Elizabeth Warren
walking back her claim that the
Democratic primary was rigged
we'll talk about NASA helping uber to
bring flying taxis to Los Angeles and
also a really weird mask has cracked
iPhone X's facial ID all of those
stories and more on the bonus show two
ways to get the bonus show david
pakman.com slash membership and
patreon.com slash david pakman show